>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" ."
THEY'D ALL ROCKET GAVE A SPEECH
TO KIDS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
VIRGINIA YESTERDAY IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
BETO HAD A MICROPHONE, SPEAKING
TO A GROUP OF STUDENTS AT A
SMALL AMPHITHEATER, AND FOR A
MOMENT, IF YOU CLOSE ONE EYE, IT
LOOKS CONVINCINGLY LIKE A
CAMPAIGN EVENT.
THERE WERE VOLUNTEERS IN
MATCHING T SEARCH FUSSING OVER
LOGISTICS.
O'ROURKE HIMSELF WORE A SLIGHTLY
DOPEY UBA BASKETBALL CAP AS HE
SPOKE, OTHER PEOPLE'S HOUSES
WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
WHEN YOU RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
TO BE CLEAR, RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IS WHAT BETO O'ROURKE
SAYS HE IS DOING.
IT IS ALL A LITTLE SAD WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
O'ROURKE IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT, AT LEAST OF THIS
COUNTRY.
HIS CAMPAIGN IS DEAD, TOTALLY
DEAD.
IT WENT TO WAS OUT LAST WEEK
FROM A FATAL OVERDOSE OF
BUTTIGIEG.
NOT EVERYONE HAS HEARD THE NEWS,
MORNING HASN'T EVEN STARTED, BUT
BETO FOR PRESIDENT IS OVER.
HE IS JEB BUSH NOW.
FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL REMEMBER
BETO O'ROURKE IF THEY RECALL HIM
AT ALL REALLY AS A MEDIA STORY.
REMEMBER THAT GUY WITH A WEIRD
NICKNAME THAT ALL OF THE DUMMIES
ON CABLE NEWS FELL IN LOVE
WITHIN A SINGLE DAY?
THAT WAS BIZARRE.
AND IT WAS BIZARRE.
>> I SAW HIM FOR THE FIRST TIME
JUST A MONTH AGO WHEN HE SAT
DOWN WITH OPRAH, AND ME AND THE
REST OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE THOUGHT WOW, THIS GUY
HAS THIS DYNAMIC, POSITIVE
ENERGY.
>> YEAH, HE HAS THAT BROUGHT
TALENT, HE IS VERY OBAMA-ESQUE.
>> WOMENS VOTED FOR HIM IN THE
SUBURBS OF HOUSTON BECAUSE THEY
HAD A KIND OF BETO CRUSH GOING
ON HERE AT >> HE IS WHOLESOME
AND EARNEST, SOMEBODY, THE TEXAS
TRIBUNE SAID SEEING HIM IS LIKEA
JESUS CHRIST SUPERSTAR, SEAMLESS
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASA
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASC
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASL
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASB
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASI
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASY
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASO
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASR
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASA
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASO
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HAST
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASH
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HASM
GUY IN FRONT OF PEOPLE COME HAS.
>> THE ROCK 'N' ROLL RUBBING 46
ARE ALL CAUGHT THE NATION'S
ATTENTION.
♪ ♪
HIS OFFBEAT SOCIAL MEDIA POST
APPEALING TO A YOUNGER
GENERATION, EVEN TAKING THEM
SKATEBOARDING AT WHATABURGER.
>> Tucker: KEEP IN MIND, THAT
JUST HAPPENED.
THE FRIENDS HE JUST OCCURRED, IT
WAS JUST LAST MONTH.
COLLEGE-EDUCATED ADULTS IN AN
ADVANCED COUNTRY WITH AIR TRAVEL
AND AIR CONDITIONING, TALKING
LIKE THAT IN PUBLIC.
PRETTY EMBARRASSING, MY GOSH.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO JUDGEY
ABOUT IT, A CONFESSION, WE DID
IT TO.
BETO'S MAGIC DISTORTED OUR
OBJECTIVITY FOR A SECOND, MAY BE
THE SKATEBOARDING OR THE WEIRD
RESEMBLANCE TO A YOUNG BOBBY
KENNEDY.
WHATEVER IT WAS, WE LOST CONTROL
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
BETO LOVES ROCK 'N' ROLL, SAYS
GMA.
HE IS NOT LIKE EVERYONE ELSE, HE
DOESN'T DO STUFFY SPEECHES OR
POLICY PROGRAMS.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BORE YOU WITH
ENTITLEMENT PROJECTIONS OR SOME
SCARY STUFF ABOUT THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
BETO HAS A SKATEBOARD AND WHERE
IS NEVADA T-SHIRTS.
HIS VISION FOR THIS COUNTRY AS
1995, THE YEAR HE WAS LIVING WAY
UPTOWN IN THIS WALK UP, WORKING
AS A MAN, KNEW THIS DUDE AT WEST
112TH STREET WITH SOME OF THE
STICKIEST BLOOD IN MANHATTAN.
A LITTLE HEAVY, BUT SWEET.
IT WAS A GOOD TIME.
BETO WANTS TO BRING US BACK TO
THAT TIME.
WE GOT A LITTLE CARRIED AWAY,
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
IT ALL SEEMED SO INNOCENT THEN,
BACK A FEW WEEKS AGO, BACK IN
MARCH OF 2019.
IT WAS BETO AND US AND A DREAM.
IT WAS A SIMPLER TIME.
WE THOUGHT ANYTHING WAS POSSIBLE
THEN, WE THOUGHT WE COULD WRITE
OUR OWN STORY.
WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT EVEN
FAIRY TALES AND, AND ONE DAY
HOURS DATE END.
THE MAGIC TURNED TO DUST, BITTER
IN OUR MOUTHS, LIKE A PEYOTE
BUTTON, ONE DAY THE MUSIC DIED.
GOODBYE, MISS AMERICAN PIE.
WEIRDLY YOUTHFUL MIDDLE-AGED
WHITE GUY WITH A HISPANIC
NICKNAME.
THERE IS A NEW HEART HEARTTHROB
IN CABLE NEWS, HE IS YOUNGER, HE
IS SHALLOWER, HE IS EVEN LESS
EXPERIENCED.
HE'S GOT AN EVEN WEIRDER NAME,
PLUS HE IS GAY.
OF THE PERFECT CANDIDATE FOR
VOTERS WHO SAY THEY LOVE
DIVERSITY BUT DON'T WANT TO VOTE
FOR STACEY ABRAMS.
THIS CANDIDATE COULD HAVE BEEN
CREATED IN A LAB AT CNN, AND
MIGHT HAVE BEEN PAID THERE IS NO
STOPPING A MAN LIKE THIS.
AT LEAST UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
ON SOME LEVEL, BETO MUST KNOW IT
IS OVER THERE HE IS NO GENIUS,
BUT HE CAN SMELL IT.
MORE THAN SIX MONTHS BEFORE THE
FIRST VOTES ARE CAST IN IOWA, HE
WILL KEEP RAISING MONEY, HIS ONE
REAL SKILL, BUT HIS POLITICAL
CAREER IS DONE.
Q. THE CENTER FRONT OF PLAYLIST.
SO WHAT ARE THE LESSONS OF THE
SINKING OF THE SSP 21.
HERE IS ONE, HE SHOULD HAVE RUN
ON SOMETHING.
IT IS HARD TO WIN ON CHARISMA
ALONE, HILLARY CLINTON RECENTLY
DISCOVERED.
SO WHY NOT BE THE ONE PERSON IN
THE RACE WITH REAL IDEAS?
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE BIG IDEAS,
HOW ABOUT EVERY       ANY IDEA?
>> ANYONE COULD HAVE TRIED THAT,
BUT INSTEAD HE STRUNG TOGETHER
CLICHES LIKE ONE OF THOSE WORD
GAMES.
REMEMBER MAD LIBS THAT USED TO
PLAY WITH YOUR BROTHER ON THE
ROAD TRIPS, THE LONG, SEEMINGLY
COHERENT SENTENCES THAT WHEN YOU
READ THEM, DON'T ACTUALLY MEAN
ANYTHING.
BETO WAS BIG ON THOSE.
HERE IS BETO DOING THAT ON THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
>> THIS COUNTRY WAS WILLING TO
SACRIFICE MEN AND WOMEN ALL OVER
THE UNITED STATES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DEFEATED GERMANY, THAT
WE WON THAT WAR, AND FOR THE
FOLLOWING 75 YEARS, WE MADE THIS
WORLD SAFE FOR DEMOCRACY.
THE GREEN NEW DEAL CALLED THAT
SERVICE AND SCALED, SCALE OF
COMMITMENT, WHEN IT TALKS ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE TODAY.
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE THE
QUESTIONS THAT BETO ASKED TO
JUST YESTERDAY AT UVA.
SO THE QUESTION FOR THE REST OF
US IS: ARE VOTERS READY TO
SUFFER, I DON'T KNOW, 400,000
U.S. COMBAT DEATHS FOR THE SAKE
OF THE CLIMATE?
WHAT DOES A CARBON DIOXIDE CANAL
LOOK LIKE?
CO TWO SIDE PAN, WILL BE FROM
TOKYO AGAIN WITH FIREBOMBS?
HOW WOULD THAT AFFECT THE
TEMPERATURE?
...
STUPID, NONE OF THIS IS REAL,
THE GREEN NEW DEAL ISN'T A DEAL,
IT IS A WISH FULFILLMENT POSING
AS LEGISLATION.
BUT HERE'S THE THING, BETO KEPT
A STRAIGHT FACE THROUGHOUT THAT
TALK LIKE HE SINCERELY MEANT IT.
WHO DOES THAT?
MEDIOCRE PEOPLE DO THAT.
MEDIOCRE PEOPLE TELL IMPLAUSIBLE
LIES AND DEMAND THAT YOU PRETEND
TO BELIEVE THEM.
IS BETO A MEDIOCRE PERSON?
WE WILL LET YOU DECIDE.
IN 2017, BETO O'ROURKE GAVE A
TOTAL OF LESS THAN 1% OF HIS
INCOME -- ONE-THIRD OF 1%, TO BE
PRECISE -- TO CHARITY.
KEEP IN MIND, HE IS A RICH, VERY
RICH.
HERE IS HIS EXPLANATION FOR WHY
HE DID THAT.
>> I SERVED IN PUBLIC OFFICE
SINCE 2005.
I DO MY BEST TO CONTRIBUTE TO MY
COMMUNITY, MY STATE, AND NOW, OF
MY COUNTRY.
THERE ARE WAYS THAT I DO THIS
THAT ARE MEASURABLE, AND THERE
ARE WAYS THAT I DO THIS THAT ARE
IMMEASURABLE HERE THERE ARE
CHARITIES WE DONATE TO THAT WE
HAVE RECORDED AND ITEMIZED,
OTHERS THAT WE HAVE NOT.
BUT I TELL YOU, I AM DOING
EVERYTHING I CAN RIGHT NOW,
SPENDING THIS TIME WITH YOU,
BECAUSE I WANT TO SACRIFICE
EVERYTHING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE TRUTH WITH EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE GOT.
>> Tucker: OKAY, SO SAVE THAT
TAPE.
THAT IS FROM UVA YESTERDAY, AND
YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO DOWNLOAD
THAT AND KEEP THAT FOR YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN BECAUSE BETO,
PEDESTRIAN AS HE IS IN SO MANY
WAYS, DID SOMETHING THAT IS
NEVER BEEN DONE OR ATTEMPTED BY
A POLITICIAN BEFORE, UNIQUE
CONTRIBUTION TO AMERICAN
POLITICAL LIFE.
BETO HAS JUST MADE THE CASE THAT
HIS ENTIRE LIFE, BETO'S ENTIRE
LIFE, IS A KIND OF CHARITABLE
DONATION.
ALL OF US GET THE GIFT OF BETO,
JUST BECAUSE HE IS HERE.
EVERY TIME BETO SPEAKS, IT IS
LIKE ENDOWING A LIBRARY IN
BURMA.
OR CURING SHINGLES IN MALAWI.
OUR BATTLE IN CHILDHOOD OBESITY
IN APPALACHIA, OR SENDING
MOSQUITO NETS TO THE CONGO.
EVERY TIME HE TALKS, WHEN HE
TWEETS, IT IS AN ACT OF CHARITY,
SOMETHING THAT MAKES THIS WORLD
WISER AND BETTER SMELLING.
HE CAN WRITE HIMSELF OFFICE
TAXES IF HE WANTED TO.
IF THE IRS WOULD HAVE TO LET
HIM.
HIS GOODNESS IS SO CLEARLY
DEDUCTIBLE, NO LAWYER WOULD
CONTEST THAT.
BUT BETO DOESN'T DO THAT, HE
DOESN'T SHIRK HIS DUTIES.